[Music]
so you started a podcast as well I sold
it in January if a penguin helped me
launch it because they you know I've and
I did it without much thought mm-hmm the
first six episodes and then Apple picks
it up they start promoting it sort of
was number one on iTunes in the UK for
about two we again I appreciate it just
launched so these things are all skewed
metrics yeah well they kind of overly
overly inflate in the early days so that
people can discover it I mean I think
it's good so that's seem really well
sand most episodes goes to number one on
health that's great
and so I've I'd love it home Absalon is
the best cuz you have conversations and
I've done so much work on the BBC where
they just edit everything and ultimately
what ends up coming out is a filtered
version of what you actually said right
and I think well I can talk to anyone I
want about anything I you know whoever
as long as you want to yes so I'm good
I'm just trying to figure out how to
there was no master plan it just
happened
but now I realize I enjoy it so I'm
trying to figure out okay how do i how
do I build a structure and a system
around this right which is tricky yeah
I'm happy to talk to you about that I
mean I'm always trying to figure out
that equation as well because once you
start to get into it you realize like oh
well this is actually there's quite a
bit that goes into it to do it well and
it takes a lot of work yeah well what
it's done for it yeah it's given us
focus you know I kind of at least every
Wednesday now way news that it goes out
social post goes out you know it's show
notes go now sure knows and didn't exist
at first people can say I said show
notes okay I'm barely getting this out
but my PA now is sort of trying to do
that as well so I kind of feel it's
growing and feel it's something I feel I
really want to own it and actually
personalize it a bit more so I'm looking
forward to it yeah yeah well you figure
out what it wants to be in the doing of
it you know yeah I love the title feel
better live more I love it and it kind
of encompasses me and what I'm about but
I think I can make more off it and we're
gonna do some live events around it you
know penguin it delighted with and
I son a two-book deal with them so we'll
do some some live events around the UK
to start with right um looking forward
see I know you've done a few of those
and a couple of them but that's great I
mean III know you're kind of in town
doing some press around the new book and
all of that and you just came from KTLA
so I watched the head a couple minutes
ago where you arrived and it's that
classic thing it's like you're there for
three minutes you know and it's like you
can just spit out like okay here are the
four pillars and then you're out right
you're right you can't really get into
it but that's like you know yeah it's
different yeah but I came out for the
feel good summit really you know Mark's
business partner drew yeah I think you
know John Andrew I really like sure he
feels he's kind of he's one of the guys
I think in my entire life who I've met
who seems to be woody in touch with who
he is he seems to me if I get that
impression anyway sort of and I wish I
was come away from it interactions for
them feeling like a better person
feeling like I know what I've got to do
I kind of really enjoy he invites me out
to come and speak and Marta to be fair
and you know once I knew I was coming
then I thought okay let me let me try
you know I got a few things if I can you
know if I'm gonna have time away from
the family and my wife and my kids I'm
trying to I'm not here for a vacation
right
basically even you know I went on a bird
in Venice having said that with a buddy
yes yeah which is good fun so I woke up
this morning feeling super lousy on the
verge of getting sick and I almost never
ever get sick like it's almost never and
if I do when it starts to come on like
it like it like it was this morning I
can usually kick it in a day but it made
me sort of knowing that I was gonna
speak to you today I was like alright
well where am I in the four pillars you
know and it's like okay well my diet is
pretty good movement I'm probably moving
too much of anything relaxation
I'm completely failing in that and sleep
I probably get myself a b-minus c-plus
right now like it's a great little cheat
sheet for taking inventory of where
you're at and it's like I know I'm
overextended right now my adrenals are
fried I'm exhausted from travel it's no
shock that I wake up and and
feel lousy so here I have the good
doctor to diagnose me have we started by
the way yeah we started oh my god I
realize we're rocking oh my god no idea
we don't start it we're just chatting
okay yeah what I mean I think before
pillar framework for me is it's just
something I can apply you can apply my
patients can apply it's just a simple
way of looking at your own health or
writing and figuring out which one of
these four areas do I need the most work
in you know because I think most of us
intuitively know you know most of us it
kind of got a pretty good idea actually
you know my diets pretty good you know
but I'm not sleeping so well and and I
love it because people get confused and
bombarded with health and health
information all the time now you get on
the internet there's a million blogs out
there often the same conflicting things
people get paralyzed you know they get
they get they just don't know what to do
with this information half my job as a
doll so when people come in is to say
okay guys you're confused okay let me
try and simplify this down for you and I
know there's a deceptive simplicity to
those four pillars but I think I really
feel it's deceptively simple because
I've seen how life-changing it can be
when people apply those in their own
life and it takes the pressure off
people it's not about a perfect diet
it's not about you know the perfect gym
routine it's about doing enough in each
area and I I'd like to think it takes
the pressure off people anyway that's
yeah well I think I mean just for people
that are listening when we're talking
about the the four pillars we have
relaxation sleep movement and food right
and what's great about the book is that
it really is super accessible and it's
like this is not you know you don't have
to like stretch and try to adhere to
some kind of protocol that only few
people are gonna actually able going to
be able to master like this is like
basic stuff but I think you know when
I'm reading it I'm like okay I get that
get that I get that this is like top
level things but it's that gap between
the information and the action where I
think most people stumbles like okay
yeah I know I need to get a good night's
sleep most nights I don't though right
yeah well that's a huge issue I mean
that's that's one of the big issues in
health you know there's all this great
information out there this great public
health messages often and people aren't
following them why are people not
following around I've got many thoughts
on that but specifically the approach I
take with these four pillars
particularly when I was writing the book
is how can I make it accessible to
people how can I write it in such a way
how can I pepper it with real-life case
studies from my practice that hopefully
people can relate to and see how just
making some simple changes and those
four key areas can have such a profound
effects and you know we can all have a
fantastic outcome when we do a 10-day
diet of some sort right when we exclude
everything from our diets we can feel
better in 10 days okay many of us can do
that but I'm interested and what changes
can I help someone with that is going to
work for them today in the short term
that's also going to work for them in
one month in six months in twelve months
and how can I help them build in this
lifestyle change mm-hmm
over a period of time and that really
has come from my practical experience
you know what what I put out in the book
is literally nearly 20 years of
experience of seeing patients and and
it's not just what the science says the
science is important to me but you know
what's even more important to me it's
actually what works and we're life you
know what will a busy mother do who
feels that they've got no time to look
after themselves and they're just
running around just doing doing doing
for their kids maybe for their partner
maybe for their elderly parents they
just go go go right I'm interested in
how can i connect with her so that she
feels yeah you know I can do that and I
know that's why I've tried to make all
their recommendations simple and
achievable and so one of the one of the
one of the most fun things
than me that I've had fed back to me
since the book came out is that people
feel that as they're reading it that I
want to do that I can make that change
you know and that that makes me excited
because I'm not telling people to go on
a punishing diets
I'm not telling people to go on a
grueling workout regime you know I'm I'm
recommending some very simple things and
why I think simple is important because
we like as human beings we'd like to
feel good right if we if I set the bar
low and we meet that it feels good you
know I've done what the doc right he's
creating a you create an emotional
engagement with that process where that
where the patient feels empowered yeah
it could be a prime example of that is
in the move pillar
okay so just in case people aren't
familiar there's four pillars and it's
there's a quarter on each of them in in
the book in the mood pillow I have got
all kinds of recommendations but one of
my favorites is something to do with
strength training so I think strength
training is very much undervalued in
society you know we don't think about it
enough and you know your lean muscle
mass it independently prediction or
mortality it absolutely determines for
in a huge pot how we're gonna be as we
get older and a few years ago I was in
my practice and I've read all the
research on it and I thought you know
I'm gonna tell my patients about
strength training I remember this guy
came in and I said you know it's really
important for your blood sugar balance
but also for your overall health that we
did a bit of strength training and he
goes what does that mean doctor said
well you know you really maybe do some
resistance at the gym maybe 30 40
minutes three times a week
guess all right okay here you know I'll
try it came back maybe four weeks six
weeks later and I said how are you
getting on I said you know what doc you
know I really want to but you know works
busy the gyms not on the way back from
work you know I just not got around to
it I thought in that instant I thought
well what's going on here you know I
didn't think why is he not doing what I
said I always thought I'm not giving him
advice in a way that he feels is
applicable to him in the context of his
life
and in that moment I came up with this
this five minute kitchen workout
basically which is okay I need to make
it accessible for him and I thought you
took my jacket off and I was literally
teaching him five moves that he could do
and I said I literally want five minutes
twice a week and that was the star for
him and literally he loved that and he
he's now doing you know two hours of
strength training a week but you start
off with that I think it's super
digestible see but I did a couple in
their 60s recently the same thing there
was so skeptical rich you know they come
over at the consultation of me they can
really you know that's what I need to do
and I said guys I tell you what I'm
gonna see you back in four weeks please
try and do these five exercises in your
kitchen right you don't need to join a
gym no to change you don't - Barney
equipment's right they went away
just a couple in their 60s and they came
out for we say sir and I said how you
guys doing said that's Jesse with love
it's changed our lives you know we start
adopting in the kitchen but now we do
every night for 10 minutes on our
upstairs landing as we run on evening
bath and I learn from my patients I I
loved reading the science but you know
getting people better in real life
doesn't come from reading scientific
papers there is a difference - how do
you convert that into into real
actionable information for people and
that's what I'm passionate about that's
what you know I you know you see all
these wars on social media about what
the new science says and what the
science says and I read them all right
but I thought we just divides people we
confuse people on what they should be
doing and and I've tried to come up with
a with a with a program and a philosophy
in this book where it's as relevant to
let's say a vegan as it is to a
meat-eater it is as well event to
someone in a low socioeconomic
neighborhood to the CEO of her top
company sorry if it's someone who's a
CEO of a company you know earning lots
of money because I'd work to some of the
poorest areas in the UK I spent seven
years in a place called Oldham you know
a lot of people on Social Security and I
thought these guys have the right to the
same
quality health information you get out
here in California right and that's what
when I was writing the book I thought I
want these suggestions that I make to
work for everyone I want to bring people
together you know I want to bring the
low carb people with the low fat people
I want to bring them together go look
what's the commonality here what can we
all focus on and that's a wheel that's
something I feel very passionate about
and and most of the recommendations I
make in fact there's 20 recommendations
not that everyone has to do the more I
say you'd absolutely don't have to do
the more you don't if you don't like one
of them don't do them you know I'm
really trying to allow people to
personalize it but 19 out of the 20 are
completely free right you can't you
can't make an argument that they cost
money the one that you can make an
argument for is when I say unprocess
your diets you know you can argue that
depending on where you live depending on
your income level you may struggle to
eat an unprocessed diet potentially in
certain parts of the country without a
bit of money okay you didn't also in the
book sort of provide a road map for how
to do that cost effectively
I do yeah and I think I think you know
one of the observation I've spent a lot
of time thinking about this subject of
you know our respective silos especially
in the diet world and what you see on
social media and the bickering and the
conflicting science and you know I'm
always thinking like well what is the
best way to to navigate this and
communicate to the audience in a way
that will be the most positively
impactful and I spent a lot of time
thinking about how to bring people
together like yourself and it's tricky
you know when people get very entrenched
in their ideologies and you know
somebody used part of the plant-based
camp I see it on all sides and
everybody's guilty of it at various
times and it's not helping anyone what
it's doing is paralyzing the average
well-intentioned consumer who's just
trying to get actionable advice to
improve their lives maybe 10% yeah I
totally agree and you know you say we're
all guilty of this from time to time
I think I'd get a bit older a bit more
experienced I think actually you know
what why does one group have to be right
why can't many different groups be right
for different people and you know we
don't often know thing about the context
of someone's life or that cultural
beliefs or how they've grown up and I
always as a practicing physician I just
bring it back to my conversation and I
think okay what am I seeing what do I
keep saying and I've seen the rouse is
if you talk about diet for example which
again we I think we overly focus on it
and what I mean by that is I think food
is very very important but food is much
more than fat versus carbs right but
your good health is much more than just
food and my own personal bias is that
when I change my diet right my health
starts improve right but that's my
personal bias because I've had many
patients who that wasn't the route they
wanted to take some of them like I've
got with so many patients who've got
mental health problems they didn't want
to change her diet even though I knew
that would help improve their their the
way they felt about themselves and their
well-being they started getting more
physically active first and then that
made them feel better so then they
wanted to change their diets and that's
that that has almost been pivotal in
this four pillar approach which is okay
guys you choose why you want to start I
don't mind if you want to start with
food right start bad but if you don't
want to start there that's okay as well
and you know I want to make this you
know did this book came out a few months
ago in the UK right and it's doing
incredibly well and I think the reason
it is doing so well is because I've
really tried hearten to not talk down to
people not to tell people what to do
nobody wants to be told what to do and I
don't you know it surprises people but
as it as a doctor I have never sit still
in nearly 20 years of practice I still
never told a patient of mine so that
they have to give up smoking and what I
mean by that is I feel that my job as a
doctor is to have an honest conversation
with them if they come into my
consultation room and if they ask me my
job is to tell them
what that is doing for their health and
their well-being if at the end of that
conversation the man or the woman says
to me hey Doc I get it I hear what
you're saying but you know what I get so
much enjoyment out of that I mean it's
not gonna quit I feel as a human being I
feel what right do I have to say to him
no you must give it up you know and
actually I think one of the reasons why
I tend to get really good compliance
with my patients it's because I do treat
them like partners I treat them like
adults even if that smoking conversation
is just setting the scene for six months
down the line or 12 months on the line
when they've thought about it reflector
we've done a bit of other work and they
come back hey you know what I might be
ready for it now and so I think you know
I think that side of things is really
really important yeah finding the the
psychological button that's gonna
activate the person and everybody has
something different there's a different
way in with every individual so you
almost have to really take like an
inventory of someone when they come into
your office to try to determine what is
the thing that that I can talk about
with this person that's gonna catalyze
change in them yeah and you know what
the hardest thing for me rich was I know
how to do that one-on-one with the
patient you know all right I'd like to
think I do you know it's it's I think
the biggest skill of the healthcare
professional is actually how do you
instructs communicate with your patient
I think that is the number-one thing
that actually leads to good outcomes I
don't care how many papers and how many
signs things you've read if you don't
know how to make it personal and
relatable to that person in front of you
doesn't matter really doesn't matter but
the system is not set up to encourage
that and that's one thing I want to
explore with you and I want to get into
the four pillars and all of that but I
think maybe it would be good to kind of
contextualise all of this by by
establishing the lay of the land right
now in terms of what is going on with
chronic lifestyle disease in North
America and the developed world because
the statistics and this you know
specifically some of the numbers that
you use in your book they're just
appalling
but beyond upholding that are
unsustainable for every single health
care system on
nancial level but on it on a human level
on it just a on a moral level you know
chronic disease is affecting so many
families and it's causing pain
disability heartache premature death
you know i-i've got a record before us
saying eighty percent of what I see as a
medical doctor in my practice is in some
way related to our collective modern
lifestyles okay I'm not putting blame on
people right because I get it it can be
tricky okay but I'm saying collectively
the way we're living our lifestyles is
having a negative impact on the way that
we feel and look there in the book
there's some us statistics but I'll give
you a UK statistic that is frankly
alarming right and this is from 2012
okay that in 2012 so what six years ago
one report suggested that the UK was
paying twenty billion pounds so that is
about twenty seven twenty eight billion
dollars always three million dollars on
the direct and indirect costs of type
two diabetes it's insane
touchy diabetes is a fully preventable
in in most cases it is a preventable
condition it is a lifestyle environments
or driven condition and we're saying
we're going to effectively if we don't
do anything different we're gonna allow
it to bankrupt our healthcare systems I
find it incredibly incredibly sad yeah
I'm looking at your book right now one
in ten Americans currently has type 2
diabetes between 1990 and 2013 rates of
this disease shot up by an incredible 71
percent in the US one of the most
dramatic increases of any nation it
costs us two hundred and forty five
billion dollars a year half of all
American adults currently suffer from a
chronic disease with one in four people
suffering from two or more chronic
diseases by a wide margin now the
deadliest problem facing America it's
true it's unbelievable it's the this is
for America this is not just a health
problem this is an economic problem you
know I think the US are gonna struggle
to be a well-functioning economy a
global power you know whatever you want
to call it with this way of Contin sees
because it
people don't often think about is this
chronic disease as affecting their whole
bodies it's affecting the way that their
brain operates as affecting their
abilities to be productive in the
workplace productive and happy and
interact with their with their families
with their work colleagues and that's
the other thing you know I see a lot of
the disharmony I see in relationships
and Families often it comes down to you
know I'm not the only thing but often a
key part of that is that people don't
feel good in themselves that without
their functioning day to day
sub-optimally mmm they're not
functioning at peak performance so they
are you know they're having little rouse
and little little problems with their
partners with their kids were their work
colleagues and often that's because
they're putting junk in the mouth right
which is affecting their brain and their
mood they're sort of only having five
hours sleep a night which is you know
you know trashing their brain in the
morning when in terms of you know you
know yourself or certainly I know as a
father you know if I am it's that well
my ability to deal with the stresses at
home and you know let things just a lie
you know well when the kids are doing
something it's much reduced I have a
slightly yeah it's not even close yeah
so a lot of these things are happening
because we're not looking after our
health and you know I think when we say
chronic disease I think it's what's
always worth explaining that we're
talking about things like yes type-2
diabetes
yes high blood pressure yes heart
disease and stroke
yes Alzheimer's disease but we're also
talking about things like mental health
problems
mm-hmm you know the latest statistic in
the UK right which comes from the mind
charity is that one in four people in
the UK are gonna have a mental health
problem and any given year I just find
it an incredible statistic and you know
we're still looking for this
pharmaceutical model of care to try and
fix these problems I could tell you it's
just simply and in a lot of cases it is
not working and them and hearing is the
crux of the matter
4050 years ago what we were seeing as
medical doctors responded very well to
the magic bullet you know you come in
right you've got it let's say you've got
a chest infection or pneumonia right
you've got the overgrowth of a bug
it's causing you this problem come and
see the dot sir they identify and give
you a pill to deserve for that bug and
they know we're in a week or maybe 10
days you're better right we could talk
about the knock-on consequences of that
but that's a separate story but that
worked 40 50 years ago the bulk of what
we see now does not respond to this you
know one pill for every L model there's
multiple things that are going on and
you it's not just one suggestion you've
got to make you've got to tackle
multiple things in one's lifestyle if
you're gonna get a results and you know
those four pillars could have been five
six seven I could have excited that it
Out's
bright Frank's got six Frank's go say
yes yeah you guys can battle it out like
is it four or six yeah exactly and the
reality is is they're the clash always
is is how can you communicate complex
health information simplistically no not
not a patronizing fashion but in a way
that actually people feel okay I get it
I can do that and I'd nearly won't
survive you know but I thought no I'm
just gonna stick to for like so I think
connection a community yeah that was one
of Frank's I think and and I actually
wondered that especially since you know
you talk about this or the Blue Zones
and the diet part and that's such a key
component of longevity from those
studies yeah oh absolutely I mean I the
connection piece I put in the relaxed
pillar so one of my recommendations is
you know to eat one reclaim your dining
table right right and it's to sit around
at least once a day if possible to have
a meal with someone else if you can and
I bring in into in that chapter white
community is so important and that
really is what I hang it off in the book
because you're white I could have made a
fifth pillar all about it but I also
think there's something in keeping it
simple simple enough that people think I
get it I can do that today I need to
wait till January next year to start
this big program this feels pretty
achievable and and I can tell you rich
where did that reclaim your dining table
come from because people might go yeah
well house I can help with my health
I'm boards I made a TV documentaries for
BBC television where I went and lived
with an alongside families to help them
with their health problems and I was
very fortunate
evert I feel very humbled to have had
that experience to be invited into
people's homes and actually actually see
in real life what they do not what they
tell me in the consultation room but
what they actually do in real life and
so many the families I stayed with
didn't sit and eat together you know
forget about what they're eating for a
minutes you know one of the kids is
maybe on the sofa scrolling there their
Facebook whilst they re saying you know
mum might be watching television but
also doing her emails and while she's
eating dad's in another room the son
somewhere else and I saw that and I
thought what was the norm I'm sure it
was a normally us just as in the UK
maybe 40 years ago that every dining
table every room every house would have
a dining table now when knocking the
mounts we're making room for big
widescreen televisions and all this sort
of stuff and I made the recommendation
to so many of those families hey guys
look you know we're not going to change
what you eat but I wonder if you guys
could manage once a day where you sit
together only as a family and I saw
their profound benefits yes they were
eating less because they were eating
more mindfully and they were connecting
whilst they were eating but there was
this couple who lovely middle-aged
couple and and I came back out for a few
days and I said how how you guys doing
with that and and the husband said to me
said it's incredible you know I'm I feel
like I'm really connecting with my wife
I'm we're sitting we never used to sit
around and without devices and have our
meal but I'm asking her about her day
I'm learning things that happens
his wife said the same thing and they
feel closer and more intimacy that just
from making that that suggestion and I
learned I didn't I didn't learn that in
my consultation room had I not gone and
stayed with those families I wouldn't
have seen that something that I thought
was well asipi normal is frankly not
normal and right right right right
yeah it's becoming
you know it's gone the way of the dodo
you know it's sort of thought of as as
antiquarian and quaint and you know at
this point but there's so much truth
than what you just said but I think the
first hurdle is really getting people to
understand on a very basic elementary
fundamental level that they have control
over their health that the decisions
that they make about how they're living
their life our to our day-to-day have
profound implications in terms of
whether they're gonna succumb to disease
or live vibrantly and I think for a lot
of people that's revelatory and new
that's brand-new even the way I was
taught at medical school really didn't
then empower us you know didn't empower
me as a medical doctor with that
information because back then we thought
our genes were our destiny right that's
kind of what we thought was going to
happen then was we've got as we do the
Human Genome Project we get more and
more we understand that you saw to do
with our genes what what cards have we
been doubts when we come out of the womb
but the last 10 years has changed all of
that you know and again the statistics
vary depending on who you read but you
know there seems to be a bit of
consensus now that about 10% of our
health outcomes for most of us is down
to our genes 90% of it is down to our
environment and our lifestyle and that's
incredibly empowering so I think there
is a generation out there who think and
have been trained to believe that it's
you know on my father had type 2
diabetes of course I'm gonna hurt RBC's
it's nothing I can do you know and in
some way that plays into the whole
emotional piece which is you know what
I'm gonna keep making these choices
because it doesn't matter you no matter
that god air I'm gonna get it so I might
as well enjoy my life rights or that's
the perception and that's the key
message I've tried whenever I speak
whenever I teach doctors whenever I talk
to the public I'm always trying to say
guys we've got the control you know
we've got more control than we think up
but just to be clear there are some
genetic conditions that are related to
you know like even even outside us for
example we know that there is under 1%
of Alzheimer's is due to your genes when
some people are born with something that
means it's very likely they're going to
get
okay but that is not the vast majority
of us and I think even that message it's
like a revelation for people and even if
I could you know help the incredible you
know people like yourself and other
doctors and other other people you
trying to spread this message around the
world if if all we do is get that
message out there that's a great
starting point because here's the other
thing right is that one of the things
that frustrates me about the infighting
on social media and on the internet
about a lot of these things is that many
people are kind of saying similar things
right so let's give you one extreme
viewpoint here no what I won't call it
an extreme viewpoint but just to sort of
paint the picture obviously there is a
lot of animosity between certain groups
whether it's a vegan plant-based versus
low carbon you know animal products you
know for an example but both groups
right are saying now that actually we
can reverse a lot of these chronic
diseases
you know both groups will say we can
reverse type 2 diabetes we can reduce
our chances of getting outsiders by
adopting our dietary pattern right right
so I trying to try to sift through that
and sit just outside it and look at it
and go okay
so compared to ten years ago when very
few people were saying that we could
reverse a condition like type 2 diabetes
oh yeah I was crazy making yeah and now
we've got this coming out from people
who may have a different viewpoint on
how the best way to do that is right but
with that they're all saying we can
reverse the stuff mm-hmm that I think is
a revelation I think we use a focus on
that go okay great so I don't
necessarily need to be on medication for
the rest of my life I might be able to
do something about this and I find that
exciting and I think that's the message
we need to get to people and then then
help them make small changes so why do
people find it so hard so many reasons
for that you know there's a lot of
emotional reasons behind that as well
but I think if we can make it seem
accessible to them if they feel you know
I can do that like one
recommendations as 15 minutes of me time
a day most people Oh 15 minutes you know
and it's incredible because that it's
like a domino effect you you start it
off simple you get people get away I can
do that I think I can manage 15 minutes
right and then that domino falls you
start to feel the benefits and then the
other dominoes start to come in line but
dr. Chatterjee you don't understand my
life I get up at 4:30 in the morning I
got four kids I got to get him dressed
into school and then I work two jobs and
by the time I get home at 10:30 11
o'clock at night and I gotta try to make
a little bit of food for my kids and I'm
just exhausted I get it I understand so
what do you think you can manage can we
start with five minutes mm-hmm do you
think you can find five minutes in your
day and that's the approach I take you
know these are just suggestions it's not
prescriptions
these are saying look I think 50 minutes
is a great starting point but if all you
can manage is five minutes right and
even that fictional lady who you know we
just spoke about I bet you she can
manage five minutes somewhere in her day
you know and that's not me being
judgmental at all I'm just saying I've
I've got patients like that and I what I
try to one-on-one is find the way and
find what is it that they do where can I
get a bit of traction here what can I
start them with I've made a deal with a
patient before that err gonna do two
minutes meditation a day right so I
can't do it I don't they said I can't
meditate I can't you know I'm not gonna
have time you know doesn't fit with my
lifestyle I said okay you brush your
teeth for two minutes in the morning
okay why do you do two minutes in the
morning so I've always done that I said
yeah you even crane that and a habit
even if you're busy you know that don't
brush your teeth for two minutes in the
morning two minutes an evening okay goes
yeah that's why we're doing I said well
how about then do you think you can
manage two minutes of meditation yeah
two minutes sure and and we made a deal
I said okay I tell you what let's make a
commitment now that you're gonna do that
she goes away she starts doing that you
know within about two or three months
you did 20 minutes a day mm-hmm so I
very much you know this comes from real
life experience rich this is you know I
I when I look back on my career and I
it I think early on in my career I
Whitney had it we are disconnect with
you know it's you know very prestigious
medical school I qualified as a
specialist and I moved to general
practice because I was always searching
for something in medicine that resonated
with me when I was working in kidney
medicine I thought I don't want to spend
my whole career just looking at kidneys
everything I always intuitively knew
everything was connected and I felt that
we were getting to super specialized in
medicine so I moved much of my much my
dad's you become from a line of doctors
you know he's a Indian doctor came over
to the UK you know they may value the
specialist right his son GP his son had
qualified this especially I've done all
the hard work to get there I said dad
you know I think I'm gonna change I'm
gonna I'm gonna be agent become a
journalist it's wide you want to have
and I've always now now that I get it
now that I understand what I love doing
with patients I can look back now and go
that's why I was slightly frustrated I
didn't get that deep enjoyment out of my
job that I do today because I just fobs
giving pills out with yes well you're a
people guy too right like I can tell
that you're somebody who enjoys
basically like figuring out what makes
other people tick and that's such a huge
part of practicing medicine that I think
we lost touch with that is now slowly
starting to come back we're seeing this
you know influx this rise of functional
integrative medicine doctors like
yourself it's become you know it's
becoming a thing and yet it's still very
much a small sliver in comparison to the
way most people are practicing medicine
and the way that most patients
experience their healthcare
practitioners and it's it's very sad is
it very sad because this is you know
this is affecting people's lives you
know it's people are dying early there
that day-to-day lives are being hindered
because you know we're not evolving with
the times the health landscape of the
developed world and actually the develop
as well is
changed so the way we practice medicine
also has to change but it hasn't and and
therein lies one of the big problems and
you know I say you know I've created I
was going to so frustrated with this I
thought okay you know I can keep talking
about out I can keep going on BBC
television and talking about this being
a problem but how we gonna start fixing
there so with a colleague of mine I
create a brand new course called
prescribing lifestyle medicine that was
the first prescribing last medicine
course to be accredited by the world
College of GPs so that's great
yeah and I we taught 200 docs in the UK
back in January we run it again in April
and why that accreditation was important
because it gave it a bit of validity it
gave it to other Doc's who were like
that yeah I kind of I'm reading all the
stuff on the internet I'm interested but
you know having the CPD points there for
people to come right legitimizes it
legitimized it and you know it took you
know we spent six months working up this
course you know we're trying to go in
one day but it's my way of trying to say
look
yes I've showcased on television that
type 2 diabetes fibromyalgia you know
can be reversed in many cases panic
anxieties has can become can come down
by 70% by making lifestyle changes
autoimmune diseases like all sorts of
things I feel like you know I've helped
showcase that to a mainstream audience
on BBC one and and in countries all over
the world there these conditions can
often be reversed but certainly
dramatically improved right by making
these changes to these four key areas
and I thought well that's great but if
the public are watching that then they
go to their own doctor for help in that
but the doctor doesn't know what to do
with that that's where we got a problem
so I thought as a medical doctor maybe I
can sit I can I can be part of the
solution by helping to educate a new a
new generation of doctors in what is
possible and what I we end the course
with a me and my colleague we we do a
role play right and people love the role
play because what we do is we on stage
we sort of go through how a consultation
might roll
when someone comes in with type 2
diabetes and the first one is what
typically happens which is you know
someone knocks on the door I'm the dog
I'm looking at my computer
you know I'm typing away the guy comes
in I barely make eye contact I'll say
hey Barry look you know you we've got
some news for you Barry and you know
pretty whirring both assaults have come
through you've been diagnosed with a
condition called type 2 diabetes type 2
diabetes you know it puts you increased
risk of heart disease
you know stroke Alzheimer's you know you
may start getting nerve damage with me
you know some people need to amputate
their legs but don't worry we've got a
great medication for that you know so
we're gonna start you on that today
within it you know we're gonna start in
something called metformin today
normally within it within six months
twelve months we'll put you on a second
pill sometimes we'll need to progress to
insulin injections but don't worry we'll
be keeping a regular eye on you and as
Barry is walking out in shell-shocked
hey and if you can lose a bit of weight
as well and go to the gym that'd be
great okay come if that is even said if
that is even said but even if it is said
like that what does the patient walk out
with they walk out with okay I've got
the condition it's serious okay but the
doc said is elusive yeah so two drugs he
can give me yeah he only met your
lifestyle that's not really that
important because you spent the whole
time talking about about drugs so I say
to people if we prioritize lifestyle the
patient will prioritize lifestyle if we
prioritize drugs they'll prioritize
drugs that's and and so you compare that
with Barry coming in and me saying hey
Barry look you know you know those blood
tests you've recently done actually a
few things that have shown up and
they're you know have a conversation you
say Barry look your blood Sugar's a
little bit high and you've actually in
the range now what we would call type 2
diabetes you know what that is I don't
know well
you explain what it is you say hey Barry
look here's the thing you will have been
doing things in your lifestyle possibly
without realizing it for a good 10 years
now that has led you up this continuum
so that you now actually have a
diagnosis of type 2 diabetes would you
like me to help you understand what
those things are how we can change them
and then hopefully if we're lucky we can
start turning this thing around yeah hey
Doc strategy I'd love to yeah well you
know let's talk
again I don't want to labor the point
but the whole dynamic is different berry
goes out of that consultation with some
actionable steps thinking hey you know
there's something I can do about this
empowered yeah but that comes to our
skill as a clinician and also our
willingness to prioritize that but in
fairness there also has to be systemic
changes to the way the entire system is
is set up I mean look you know doctors
are well-intentioned they want to help
people they'll actually they want to be
healers that's why they get into it but
when the system is constructed such that
they have five or ten minutes with each
person it's it's it's it's set up to
fail in that way so like I love the fact
that you created this this program but
you know it needs to be across the board
in the medical schools like from the
very beginning doctors need to be
trained in all of this stuff and
systemic changes have to be made that
allow for that kind of bandwidth with
each patient so that that person can
leave with that sense of empowerment
rate you're absolutely right and you
know ultimately this is not just gonna
be the doctor you know this is arguably
you know we need to collaborate more
with nutrition professionals with health
coaches you know but what I'm what I say
to people is people say to me sometimes
why do dogs need this training you know
why can't dogs just refer to the right
people and there's a fundamental
misunderstanding of what our job is you
see because if we don't know right okay
we've so we can't talk to diabetes and
let's say obesity right these are things
which are obviously for many people
relate it to our lifestyle okay so so
arguably we might refer here okay what
about conditions like mental health
problems right what about something like
migraines which affects cause huge
disability you know huge morbidity
across the population what about these
problems where we don't automatically
think that lifestyle has a role well I
know full well and I've seen that you
can absolutely make a huge impact with
these patients with lifestyle changes
unless we get the training we're never
ever gonna meet even referring these
guys to health coaches or lifestyle
professional
to help them yeah you wouldn't even know
- do you even know to do that's you know
I I gave it a lecture it was in Bristol
in the UK in January where for the world
College of GPs on on wellbeing for
doctors cuz burnout in physicians is a
huge problem and I said to these guys at
the start I said how many of you with a
patient who comes in with a mental
health problem like depression how many
of you talk about food with those
patients and you know but 5% at the room
put the hand up then I presented some of
the science behind it including you know
there's a beautiful trial from February
2017 called the smiles trial in
Australia very small okay but it was
some randomized control trial that
people who followed a modified
Mediterranean diet these are all
patients of with depression moderate or
severe depression they were already on
therapy nothing of that none of that was
changed but one group went on a modified
Mediterranean diet for 12 weeks the
other group had some sort of talking a
social therapy and the end of 12 weeks
there were statistically significant
remission rates in the group who went on
a modified Mediterranean diets now there
was only 67 participants but that adds
to the weight of evidence it is already
building and I said guys look how many
of you now are gonna have this
conversation with your mental health
patients and pretty much everyone put
their hand up because but you know
something that seems so obvious to me is
not mainstream knowledge amongst these
professionals
so yes the training needs to help that
you know this training needs to be
compulsory in medical schools are
absolutely agree as Sibylla said when we
put on this course they you know because
everyone's you know a social media
expert these days is like you know this
is not enough you know you need to get
into medical schools I agree with all
that but you got to start somewhere else
start yeah gotta start somewhere you got
to give this movement credibility the
mental health piece is is so huge and I
think you know I'm interested in your
experience like if you when you start
talking about treating mental illness or
things like depression through lifestyle
alterations people get nervous yeah
right because we're just used to
thinking of it a little bit differently
than we think about physical health but
it is so
Villa tating for so many people and it
kind of lurks in the shadows and you
know my experience is in working with
lots of people and being part of the
recovery community for many years is
that even when you're amongst people who
are very high-functioning who seem like
they have everything together if you can
get them in a safe environment where
they have an inkling a slight
willingness to be vulnerable and you
just poke them ever so slightly you'd be
amazed at what comes out we're all
dealing on some level with all kinds of
stressors and anxieties that are really
indicia of our times like how we live
our lives now is so antithetical to the
natural rhythms of you know how we
evolved yeah I mean absolutely and you
know there's this theory about sickness
behavior which is if we think about the
body and our stress response system okay
and well let's say in Paleolithic times
that we had come down with an infection
okay so we're where our immune system
goes on high alert
so produces all kinds of inflammatory
markers to help us fight that infection
but what it also does is make us die it
makes us sleepy and makes us withdraw we
don't take pleasure from things and it
almost sends us back to the back of the
cave in the dark so we can just rest and
recuperate
you know whilst the body is attacking
what it needs to attack and a lot of
people speculate and that actually is
very similar to what's going on with
mental health problems it's potentially
an appropriate or an inappropriate
response
well it's something that was an
appropriate response in a different
environment but as the environment has
changed our 21st century living that
response is actually doing us harm now
but it but it served this very well in
the past and I kind of like that because
it really helps me understand why does
our body have all these mechanisms at
play why why things suddenly start to go
wrong with all these different systems
in our body and what's changes the
environments but the other great point
you bring out rich is that you know life
style you know was I got to a mental
health you know that's a and
and what I would say to that is and I've
got me very key very careful to caveat
is is that any chronic disease even type
2 diabetes but let's talk about mental
health there are multiple factors that
play a role it ain't just one thing so
yeah you may have huge emotional trauma
at the knees dealing with right but it
doesn't mean you can't also get an
improvement from optimizing your
lifestyle and it's it's not necessarily
one or the other we're always looking
for what is it is it emotional or is it
physical or maybe it's a combination and
I talk a lot in in my birkin in my sort
of work that I do as for the thresholds
right
we've all got an individual threshold so
the way I trying to explain is if if if
we're born in perfect health let's say
we start down here in perfect health we
can deal with multiple insults up to a
point so let's say you know I don't know
we had a ton of antibiotics as a baby
okay
we didn't enjoy our school you know we
got bullied at school we need to poor
diet we don't workout we worked too hard
we got very very close to our threshold
then something happens you know you have
a bereavement in the family or your
girlfriend breaks up with you and that
tips you over your threshold that's when
you get sick and we think oh it was the
last thing that we need to fix no it's
you want your posture once you cross
your threshold you need to start again
it's like in life you've got one ball
two ball two juggling three four right
you're just about keep everything going
that someone throws a fifth ball then
everything falls down and so my approach
is about making multiple changes and so
no on the on the last series a doctor in
the house there was a lady white who had
a significantly traumatic emotional
event when she was 19 right you know
ended up in intensive care in a coma she
woke up she was scared out of her mind
since that she had really bad panic and
anxiety attacks okay which is crippling
her life and she applied to be on the
show because she was desperate she had
tried counseling she tried
antidepressants and nothing was working
I didn't know if I was gonna be able to
help or not but I thought okay what's
going on here her diet was appalling you
know she was compensating with the way
she felt with junk food and processed
food you know she was up late on her
screens all this kind of stuff right and
again she was very skeptical when I
suggested that we would start by
changing her diet you know there was a
huge resistance well you know you're
saying I'm I've done this to myself with
a food on me I don't know no I'm not
saying that I'm saying that something
significant happened when you were 19
but you have you know because of the way
you felt you put loads and loads of
layers onto that as well and lots of
compensated behaviors around that let's
just start you've tried counseling you
tried antidepressants okay let's take a
different approach so we started with
her diets and it was just incredible by
at the end of six weeks her symptoms had
gone down by 70 percent not miraculous
reversal but her quality of life had
improved immeasurably and I feel and
towards the end we then got her to a
talking therapist but she was in a much
better state that she can now access
that and deal with that and you know we
we've got it sorry so labor the point
but you've got to do multiple things in
multiple areas and that's why this is
not a book about food this is why it's a
book about yeah there are many great
books on food I'm not against that right
but I think what that stuff is out there
right what can I contribute I want to I
want to show people that the quality of
your sleep is as important as a food
that you put in your mouth and I didn't
know that five years ago and you may be
skeptical of that potentially but you
know when you look at the research of
what sleep deprivation does to us you
know I I have help patients reverse or
suddenly put their type 2 diabetes into
a mission yeah there's something in the
book about insulin resistant the impact
of poor sleep on insulin resistance
which I I did not know how significant
that was it was curtly it's crazy it's
huge and was a study recently done where
they sleep deprived a healthy group of
people it's down to four to five hours a
night which is not dissimilar to what a
lot of the pollution a lot of people and
a lot of people will swear that they're
fine with that a lot of II will sweat
okay with that but here's the thing a
lot of the time so there's two points
there when you say people say they're
okay with that if we go back to my
threshold analogy okay they may find
that that sleep deprivation in the they
may not have any symptoms yet they may
be getting away with it
right but they may be moving up towards
their threshold so they that sleep
deprivation may be okay day to day they
may perceive it as being okay but then
when when the stress goes up at work
when something happens that they're not
expecting when they lose their job or
their mother gets sick suddenly they're
that much closer and they tip over and
that's why I think you know we were all
we we exist on a continuum of health you
know when you get diagnosed with type 2
diabetes that started 10 years ago right
of course when you get diagnosed with
Alzheimer's disease that started 30
years ago right so we need as a system
we need to better help people identify
when they're moving up that curve when
they're not at diagnosis stage but
they're moving up that curve but the
thing with sleep deprivation and I've
got patients who come to see me who's
they have changed their diets they've
read the blogs why they've whether it's
plant base whether it's another approach
they've read all that and they've
changed that and I come in and I see
them and their blood Sugar's still
aren't coming down I think your diets
pretty good you know and then some of
them super stress and they're not
sleeping and there was one particular
case 52 you're a guy you know busy you
know high performer executive his diet
was fantastic but he was getting so
frustrated that he couldn't get his
sugar down anymore and when I started to
say look we need to think about
switching off your computer one hour
before bats we need to do five minutes
of meditation a day right just to get
you started his you know six months
later his blood sugar starts coming down
you know because it's not always diets
and that really is the you know I'm not
trying to say oh it's not important it
is clearly very very it's just not all
diet it ain't all time and I think
that's what get when you get into these
silos and these arguments you know this
sort of implicit message is it is all
diet right and yeah diets huge it's
super important but beyond that there's
so many things you could be the most
perfect
raw vegan fruitarian whatever but if
you're bananas and you argue with people
all day long and you're an [ __ ] and
you don't sleep at night and you're
staring at your phone all day long like
you're not a healthy person yeah you're
not and if we go back to sleep for a
second that study where they deprive
people's a four to five hours a night
for I think six nights okay
they had a 40% reduction in that
capability to manage that blood sugar
the end of that some of them would have
been diagnosed as pre-diabetic right
just from sleep deprivation Wow and I
think we've got to stop bringing this
into the equation because you mentioned
the blue zones I talked about the blue
zones and I find them fascinating
because we can learn so much and then
that when you know I know you've had
down on the show before and you know I
had the privilege of meeting Michelle
Palmer who's the Belgian researcher who
I think along with Dan helps her sort of
coined the term and do all that work I
met him in Guernsey last year which is
just incredible experience for I'll tell
you about actually Beth when we look at
them and we try and look at the perfect
diets I understand the rationale behind
that but we're looking at a populations
who are reaching well they're also
pretty physically at they're physically
active everyday they're sleeping well
they've got low levels of stress and
they've got a strong sense of community
right so when we look at them it's a
lifestyle it's the whole piece put
together and when we compare in the west
where we are under slept what overly
stressed were physically inactive and
where a lot of us are eating highly
processed junk food right that's just a
recipe for trouble and we can't I don't
think just take one aspect to the Blue
Zones we have to look at it all and go
you know let's let's try and optimize as
many of these as we can and the other
the other thing I sort of Lutzer sort of
try and get across is I get it life is
tricky for some people you make work
shifts right you may find it hard right
so maybe if your sleep pillar ain't
going very well maybe need to optimize
the food pillar and the movement pillar
and the relaxation pillar you know you
can get to your you can lower your
threshold in many different ways and I
think the Blues are a prime example of
people lowering their thresholds you
know in keeping themselves very
resilient because that's the thing
lowing keeping yourself away from that
threshold doesn't just mean you're gonna
feel better
you've got more resilient so when life
does Chuck you its curveballs and that
will happen nothing stays static
everything's always changing you're more
resilient to fight ends yeah and I think
you know it's only getting crazier I
mean with these you know devices in our
pockets it's becoming harder and harder
to to detach to disconnect and you know
what's gonna happen 10 20 years from now
it's gonna be almost impossible to
unplug at all and the pace of life just
continues to to get rapid ER and rapid
ER and you know there's no there's no
like you actually have to work to be
bored now there's just no there's no
reason to ever be bored again we can be
over stimulated during every minute of
every waking hour we we've lost the art
of stillness we've lost that ability to
just sit there and let our mind wander
and actually that's been a lot the
creativity happens you know your your
default mode Network your dmn in your
brain which is where a lot of these
creative ideas come from that goes into
overdrive when we're not focusing on a
task when we're just sitting there you
know just watching the world go by or
maybe when you're going for a run I I'm
gonna bet that you get a lot of your
great ideas when you're out running oh
yeah absolutely
rather than when you'll only time or I
can just be by myself in my thoughts in
nature yeah cuz you're not trying to sit
here figuring it out got this problem I
can't I can't get to the bottom of this
you probably got for everyone right I've
got the solution right or when I am
grinding it out and trying to figure it
out I'm like let's see what's happening
on Twitter I'm gonna stare at my phone
now I obviously gave a talk to Apple in
London on wellbeing for their employees
and you know it could be you know
privileged to feel very humble to go in
there and talk to them and I actually
spoke some about tech and I said I feel
I felt like I was in the Lions Den
talking about tech and some other
problems but also how what a great
opportunity they've got because so many
people use their products
they can actually shape the world well
you know they if it's and I think they
do take some of these things responsibly
you can actually really shape what
people do but what was interesting I
spoke about my four pillars for them so
try and improve their well-being and at
the end of the talk this chap came up to
me he must have been in his mid-twenties
right he said hey you know Dulce I found
that really were the interesting but can
I ask you something I said yeah sure far
away it's like if I switch my phone off
an hour before bed what am I gonna do
which he was serious man
yeah I'm not kidding this is it this is
a Kanak panic he was deadly serious and
I thought that I learn a lot that I
thought wow as she for some people
they're so embedded to this they
genuinely don't know what they're gonna
do without it and I thought you know
I've got two young kids seven and well
know now eight eight and five years old
and I I'm worried about this you know as
a father there's always something to
worry about as a parents and I think
what making a do very soon everyone in
my son's class is gonna have a phone and
he's gonna be like daddy can I have one
and he already asked it for his birthday
recently and you know I looked at he's
thought you know I'm not getting that
with that you know I know what the
answer is but I I worry because I don't
want to make my children social outcasts
yeah I really struggle with knowing some
of the problems I yeah it's a legit
salad JIT concern I mean I'm older than
you but you know I didn't grow up with
you know I didn't start using a computer
until I was in college and that was
still many years prior to the internet
so you know myself and to some extent
yourself like were the last generation
of people to know what it's like to be
without all of these things there will
never be another generation of humans
who never lived through you know what
it's like to not be on the Internet and
so it is tricky you know as a parent
myself to try to find that that balance
because on some level we have to accept
the fact that that these devices are
part of what it means to be fluent in
the language of our times so it's not
about like no you can't have it it's
about creating responsible habits around
which is difficult when you're talking
about a device that has the addictive
potency of heroin I mean you've just hit
the nail on the head
it's not about demonizing these devices
and tell this technology's fantastic
it's it's utterly life-changing you know
we can we're having like what we're
doing right now do right now you know or
you know we could have done this let's
say over Skype right we could have been
5,000 miles away from each other having
a conversation because of this
technology which is utterly incredible
and I think what we have to just
remember is that this is a new
technology right we haven't quite yet
figured out as a human race how do we
use it in a way that it really helps us
and serves us rather than enslaves us
and just as we've got like sleep hygiene
rules I think we need technology hygiene
rules we needs you know what a good
practice rules you know do we need a
better tech free time every day i
absolutely believe we need a better tech
free time every day but here's the thing
if you've got that device near you it's
very very hard because they are
addictive you know and I you know one of
the sort of recommendations I make is
you know can you have a screen free
Sabbath can you have one day a week
without a screen completely now I get it
people are gonna almost be having
palpitations at before what am I gonna
do yeah so I say what if you can't do a
whole day try with it try an hour start
there I tell you on a Sunday morning
right if I go with my wife or my two
kids to the to the local park right if I
go and my phones in my pocket right it
goes something like this kids are
playing rawlins right saying before you
know it I'm just he there on the
climbing he's got a cheek a little look
you know what's going on an Instagram
what's you know and then for you yeah
where are the kids you know that's
something like that that's somebody
abducted them yeah but before you know
it you're into this work because it's
powerful it's engaging if I make the
decision I'm leaving my phone at home
I've completely different experience I'm
present I'm mindful I'm paying attention
to what's going on and my kids know
you're not a panicky and feeling naked
yeah no I love it but I've got used to
it yeah I've got used to it and and
ultimately my kids basically my daughter
she'll call me out
if I'm in the room with her somewhere
and I'm distracted on my furniture that
daddy not listening to me are you
I say that's like a dagger in the heart
for me and I might okay yeah I'm just
gonna put my phone off in another room
and so I as a father one thing I think
it's really important it's something I
really try and adhere to is spend at
least one hour a day with my kids when
I'm around you know without my phone
anywhere in sight and not even on
because I just that's my strategy again
I'm not saying everyone has to do this
I'm just saying I'm trying to figure it
out I'm as addicted to this technology
as anyone elses I'm trying to figure out
a way what I can still get the best of
it without harming myself and also my
relationship with my kids in the process
yeah well when you figure it out let me
know it's hard right it's hot it's
really hard you know I I mean it's like
an AI like I make my living through this
you know through through this ecosystem
so it's even more difficult for me to
create because I can just make a
justification well this is what you know
I need to be doing I need to be I got a
promote the latest podcast and you know
as somebody who's a recovering alcoholic
like it just pings every part of my
brain that like wants to use and check
out and get that little brush but what's
the dip you say you know you can add it
to alcohol but let's talk about food for
a minute people will often say yeah I
could eat well for a short pretty time
that I've fallen off the wagon I
couldn't do it you know I've and and
it's the same thing with these phones
it's what I'm not expecting perfection
from people know a it's not my right to
expect perfection from anyone but I'm
not that's not what I'm I'm trying to
suggest and what I what I do with
patients what I do with when I speak to
the public or or in the book I I mean
what I'm trying to do is empower people
with information say look guys this is
what's going on right this is gonna be
having impacts on you here are some
strategies that you might want to adopt
why do you suck it and see why don't you
try this you like this one you don't
like this one fine you've tried it that
doesn't work for you try this one I mean
one thing I will say is one of the most
life-changing things people can do
okay is takeoff notifications right and
I'm deadly serious you don't need you
know that's the way you can start taking
control of that technology and go I
don't need to be notified every single
time someone likes my Instagram post or
my latest Facebook article or someone's
just retweeted me I don't need to be
notified every time you know so all my
notifications are off my email inbox is
on manual refresh so I can look at my
phone I could have 20 emails waiting for
me I don't know I have to go into the
app and I have to you know refresh the
screen right and then I see and you know
that's a small step that I think most
people can manage and I would say to
people listening this who attempted to
do something I'd say start there just
stop there that's one thing I have done
and that was life-changing all the
notifications on my phone are off the
one thing where it gets me into trouble
though is when you take notifications
off your text messages because there's
an expectation when someone texts you
that that you prompts an immediate
response you come from well I don't know
maybe it's it's self-generated in my own
mind but I've trained now like I just I
I basically unless it's really pertinent
I don't respond to text matches messages
right away so that people who text me
don't then develop that expectation but
I don't know if you've noticed this like
texting has now become like email it's
like it's almost like my I used to just
not get that many texts but now I get so
many texts that it's like the same thing
but then I don't think to check my texts
because I don't have that little number
on there I don't know when I have new
ones yeah it's you know I can also
grayscale your phone too which i think
is it great what's that you know
familiar with you there's a setting
where you can go in and take and remove
all the color and so it's just black and
white screen and there's something about
the way that everything is colored in a
specific way there's a lot of money in
science that's gone into you know
creating that compulsive addictive
response and color has a big role in
that so there's been studies done that
when you grayscale your phone that that
it really tempers that compulsivity yeah
there's a guy called Tristan Harris he's
doing like a lot of Reese
search in this right now doing the
podcast rounds and super fascinating
super interesting yeah you know
communications changing as an ad saying
like text messages are becoming a bit
more like emails and it's very hard now
to it's very hard to put those
boundaries in now you know I I try my
best to guard my number my phone number
with my life you know because that then
means people have got access to me got a
Sunday on a Saturday you know when I'm
on family time and those boundaries have
just got blurred now and it's funny you
know I also think that we we've lost an
element of respect on other people's
time and their boundaries not because
we're meaning to but I give an example
recently somebody who's got my number
added me to a whatsapp group off like 15
people 14 of which don't have my number
and when it first happened I was you
know come on I'm on this whatsapp group
now and these 14 people who don't have
my number have now got my number so they
can contact me personally in a way that
they couldn't do before and again I'm
not it's nothing about ego or anything
like that it's just more I'm really
trying to try to guard my own personal
time my private space and I feel that's
been taken away from me now and the
person who did it didn't do that with
any malice right we haven't really
written the etiquette rules exactly and
that's what I think is is going to be
written over the next few years and now
is what is what is the right s kit like
as you say there's an expectation of the
text message you should be responding so
you're helping to educate your community
or friends people who have access to you
via your text you're helping to just
educate them a little bit go hey you
know when you text me I'll get back to
you but it won't be quick mm-hmm and I
think we all have to do that you know
Tim Ferriss wrote in his in the 4-hour
workweek you know about that's when I
learned about the emails about police
setting the expectation when someone
said she'd you know this email gets
checked twice a week or once a day you
know I did that for a while then I took
it off and you know I'm always
experimenting but it's about changing
the expectation rights yeah he was he
was he already showed me
found in it it said that he had like
8000 unread emails or something like
that and I was like do you read them and
then mark them unread he's like no I've
never looked at them and I did an
experiment when I was in as I told you
before the podcast just got back from
Italy I did an experiment where I had a
colleague of mine my assistant handle
all my emails while I was gone I'd never
like turned over my entire email box to
somebody else and gone away for like two
weeks and not looked at it and that was
a that was definitely a learning
experience it was a great but it was
like for a minute there I felt very
weird you know almost like naked yeah
yeah yeah that's your thing and and I
think the key is you say is it we don't
know the rules yet we're all trying to
figure this out we're in the infancy of
the most powerful technology that we've
ever created yeah we're trying to find
our way and we're worse were we're
stumbling without the you know the tools
yet yeah I mean this is such such a huge
impact on us I don't think we even
realize you know how big this isn't but
I'd go as far as saying that this
arguably our stress component in our
lives and the way we use our technology
for many of my patients is arguably more
important than the food that they're
putting in their mouth right it is to be
on the entire time to wake up and go
first thing on that on that phone and
the noise that comes in from that
constantly throughout the day and often
it's still going on when we're in bed at
night lying there still checking
everything no downtime that is having a
huge consequence on the way many of us
feel and you know I actually I think I
start a book with a story about the 16
year old boy who I saw maybe six years
ago it's this chap called Devon and this
was in a typical conventional medical
practice you know in our National Health
Service I have 10-minute appointments
and it was a Monday afternoon surgery
okay we call them surgeries they're just
clinics basically okay among the
afternoon clinic I had about three or
four people in the waiting room I was
already running a little bit late and
this sixteen-year-old boy walks in with
his mother I open up the file and I see
there's a letter basically on the
Saturday this got ended up in the ER
because he tried to Harmon
self and there was a letter there from
the ER doctor saying hey dr. Shashi look
this is what's happened we assessed him
he was safe to discharge but could you
please start one antidepressants so he's
that he's with his mom
I sort of know the family anyway because
I've been looking after a period of time
and I thought okay what's going on err
why is a 16 year old boy from a
seemingly well-balanced family that I've
never really detected any issues with
before
why is he ended up harming himself in
the ER Department on the Saturday I just
can't stop on an antidepressant I need
to figure out what's going on here I
just couldn't do it so I spent maybe 10
20 minutes with them and I thought I
need a bit more time there said guys
look are you able to come in tomorrow
morning at the end of my morning clinic
and I spend a bit longer with you
I said yes sure so they came in the
following day at the end of that I
thought I can as many factors at play
here the one thing really worries me
which is his use of social media and his
smartphone and I said to him I said look
Devin would you be interested in
reducing and me helping you reduce your
usage is that gonna help
I said well look I don't know but I
think I don't think it's helping your
current mental state would you be
willing to give it a go and he was a you
know that low app and he said yeah sure
if you think it's gonna help so we
agreed for the first week that just for
one hour before bad he'd switch off his
phone and he won't go on the internet he
comes about seven days later and I said
to him you know how you doing he said
well you know dogs chassis um I'm still
not great but I feel less up and down in
the day I was sleeping better I just you
know I've got a bit more energy things
aren't quite as bad as they were I said
okay so you've already seen that that's
having a little bit of an impact what if
we increase that a little bit more and
over the next few weeks we increase up
to two weeks two hours in the evening
before bed and two hours in the morning
where he doesn't go on his phone mmm-hmm
okay he's starting to feel better not
cured or anything but significantly
better then I thought okay we tackle
that he's getting that better then I
also then went into his diets said hey
what are you eating it was a typical
teenage diet lots of highly processed
sugary junk food snack
King all throughout the day and I said
hey Devin did you realize that actually
that food that you weeds can have an
impact on your mood so really I said
look what happens when you have this
food right that we simply some like you
know when you're eating this food you're
this high sugar foods you're getting a
blood sugar roller coaster so what
happens you're having that in the
morning before school mid-morning your
Sugar's crashing fast that's not just an
energy poem that's not just a sugar
problem that is also a mood problem
because when it crashes that your stress
response goes up in your body adrenaline
cortisol go up right this will have an
impact on your mood hormones you're
saying are you kidding me I know this is
what this is this will be playing a role
here so because he understood why I was
asking to make the changes it wasn't
just me saying you've got to change your
diet I drew out a little graph for him I
explained to him he goes okay that makes
sense
show me right so I explained what he
might be able to do you know take some
nuts with him for those snacks to keep
his blood sugar stable throughout the
day those kind of things it wasn't a
perfect diet he didn't go full-on
Mediterranean right he just made enough
changes and then he started to improve
again bit by bit he's getting better and
then I stopped seeing him suddenly he
doesn't come in as much I'm getting on
with my busy practice and then I come in
about six months later and there's a
letter um you know as part of my mail
and go through I open this letter and
it's from Devin's mom and he says dear
daddy I just want to thank you you've
completely changed Devin's life he he's
happy at school he's interacting with
his friends he's joining local clubs at
the weekends he's just you know he's
just a joy to be around I just want to
say thank you I've learned so much from
that case which cuz I thought wow yes I
think there are emotional issues as well
but simply by tackling two of those four
pillars right the relaxed pillar where I
helped him reduce the social media hues
by helping him understand what was going
on I helped him improve his diet by
maybe 20 30 percent it's not full-on
right he started to be empowered enough
to see how that impacted his lights on
so this is a 16 year old boy he was at
he was at a fork in the road what he
could go down one path I'm on my
antidepressants
I've got two
right the still label I've got no doubt
he would have been put on a repeat
prescription he could still have been on
that five years later but at that moment
he took another path he now has
empowered himself you know really helped
him to understand how the environments
or choices he makes impacts his mental
health and I very much hope that that's
going to keep him in good stead going
forward because if things get tough in
the future he will know actually there
with them things I might be able to do
which it going to help me
and really this what I'm saying this for
proach is deceptively simple right we
think you know where's the real medicine
where's where's the cool stuff right
this is the cool stuff if you get this
stuff for riots everything gets better
yeah if you're lucky you can reverse
your disease but you can certainly
improve the way you feel pretty much
everybody can improve the way they feel
you know whether you've got a disease or
not if you're just someone who's who
wakes up tired every day and needs sugar
and coffee to get you through each day
these principles are gonna help you
mm-hmm if you got type 2 diabetes is
gonna help you it doesn't matter cuz
he's a universe I can't invent the
principles of good health but the same
principles that existed under my god
come out with a new car separate book
and say hey guys I've got the secret
right I don't
it's the secret no one wants to tell you
that you've never heard before yeah I
mean I think the most powerful thing in
all of it is getting the lights to go on
in the patient like by making you know
like a lot of the book is about like
look let's just these baby steps right
and if you can just get a patient to
implement one or two of those the lights
go on they start to make that connection
between how they're living and how
they're feeling and then they're
invested and then you're basically
catalyzing that person's journey for the
rest of their life they're gonna go off
and you know continue to grow and
explore and refine and change and do all
of that you know on their own with
guidance of course from people like
yourself but it's that empowerment piece
that I think is so important and I think
it's a fundamental paradigm shift in the
doctor-patient relationship from one of
you know the traditional paradigm of
like I'm the expert you're going to do
what I tell you
and there's no we're not we're not in a
partnership here like you know I'm the
authority to okay let's sit down and
have a chat and like we're we were a
team here and what can we do together
where it does it fosters that sense of
self determinant ISM yes upon a shape
it's got to be a partnership between
doctor and patient because those days of
that paternalistic relationship they're
over they're gone
I mean there's still a certain
generation who expects that they're
still I mean yeah most of it is that way
still most of it's that we're the rarity
still I think I've always been slightly
odd in the head because I've never seen
it like that I've always kind of wanted
to have that punch at that conversation
I've always but it didn't start that way
for you like we didn't even tell the
story about how you got into all this
yeah and so well you know it's
interesting that because I reflect back
now on my career and you're right it
didn't start that way but on some level
it did so you know to put it in
perspective is I qualify for a writer at
medical school and I thought I've got
all the skills now I need to get out
there and make people better great so
I've trained for let's go for make dad
proud
yeah exactly you know and family proud
and all this kind of stuff that you know
I grew up with and I I woke up and I'm
you know doing acute medicine and then
within a couple of years I'm you know
leading the cardiac arrest team and the
hospital and doing all this all the kind
of cool acute stuff that you think being
a doctor is all about
but actually I reflect back and I think
even then I don't think I was deeply
satisfied I you know I saw how powerful
modern medicine can be for a keep
promise people walking in through the
door
sick and you give them whatever you need
to give them and suddenly they're
transform just incredible so you know
witty question at the time you don't
even know you're saying hey we go so med
school really early and in the UK we
don't do a degree we first so you know
what I qualified as a doctor I must have
been 21 I'd say no really wow that's way
earlier something like that maybe 22 you
know and I I think now I think I didn't
even have the life experience
be able to understand what people were
going through but the point is I I was
you know I was okay my career was going
fine and I was doing my specialist exams
and I thought yeah okay fine I'm gonna
figure this out and you know and you've
alluded to you know my my personal story
which is that's you know I had already
made the move to general practice
because I was I really felt that we were
just missing the big picture and we were
just getting so down rabbit holes in one
area without seeing how everything is
connected and I was working general
practice and you know we just had a
first child you know my my wife had
breast fed him for the first six months
as per the guidelines and as well you
know we thought we doing the best thing
and I'm not saying we won't do the best
thing but we were you know we're pretty
healthwatches family and we went on
holidays of farms and the Christmas
holidays and you man okay I can still
remember it so vividly that we were
staying in my my friend's chalet in a
place called chemin e in France and they
weren't there yet we were just there and
my son hadn't been well throughout the
day he had a bit of a cold and for some
reason my wife didn't put him down in
his in his cots which is in the basement
didn't feel why it's a you know maternal
intuition whatever you want to call it
she didn't do that and then I remember
that she was sitting was a big open
plans you know living room and kitchen
and she was sitting there and I think I
had the kettle on and she just called
out something and said you know wrong
and he's stopped moving come you know he
just shouted out I just came over he put
my son at his arms had gone back he was
rigid and he just stopped and you know I
thought he was choking I I thought maybe
he was choking on his mucus and his
flame and you know my sort of my medical
training was sort of like okay so I
turned him over I try to clear his
airway who's not breathing is it's not
breathing it's just you know I frankly I
try to clear his airway nothing was
happening and in that moment I wasn't a
highly qualified doctor I was a I was a
scared dad and I froze right I was just
standing there what's going on I've got
to figure this out on my wife I said
look we just got to get to the hospital
so we rush into the car you know I
almost kill us all because we own this
little slope and car skids because I'm
just so panicked we end up in the
hospital which isn't very far and you
could see when we got there that the
doctors are worried because you know for
people who don't know a six-month-old
child can have a convulsion it's called
a febrile convulsion if they've got a
fever with it that is not actually that
worrying that can happen in that age he
had no fever so you could see the
doctors were really panicked too sir
okay what's going on here why is he got
no fever because that's that's the
common calls mmm you know they were
sticking a net a line in his neck you
know all kinds of stuff that he had to
be blue lighted down the mountain to the
big mountain hospital cuz we were in a
little resort but they get him breathing
the kind of breathing they gave him
diazepam to get him going you know and
stop all that sand I wasn't allowed in
the ambulance so I had to follow it in a
car and I was just panicked what the
hell was going on we no one knew they
took blood from him he had two lumbar
punctures you know we thought we've been
a losing battle oohed Lee so scared I
feel as later the daughter comes into
the room and he says you know those
shattered we know you know he's you know
we know what's happened as a well what's
happening said he's got a very low level
of calcium and because of that low level
of calcium he's had a convulsion so what
we call a hypocalcemic convulsion okay
fine they didn't know why at that point
they just said okay this is the cause so
it's put it in perspective the the
normal calcium level on that particular
test is 2.2 to 2.6 even if we see it at
1.9 we consider that very low his was
0.97 so his was tanked you know barely
compatible with functioning that's why
he had his convulsion so they gave him
an intravenous calcium infusion you know
this what modern medicine does best
right
fix that a key problem but then what
happens I think about an hour or two
later I can't even remember the time you
know it's all a bit of a blur but he
said you know we we now know why he has
no vitamin D in his body is very very
low so because he has no vitamin D his
calcium has dropped low
so to cut a long story short and I'm
sorry to have labor at the point it's
just it gets quite emotional when I
think back and I'm you know I still
can't clear that that out of my heads
terrifying
and in a nutshell this is a fully
preventable problem right
my son nearly died from a preventable
vitamin deficiency and his dad as a
highly qualified specialist general
practitioner immunology on his degree
you know all this kind of stuff all
these labels right wish I had I wasn't
able to prevent that happening in my son
but how would you even know I mean if
he's breastfeeding you would be you
would presume that he's because
ultimately you know I now know that and
again people are gonna listen to go what
why weren't you putting in more vitamin
D maybe and the reality is is that you
know that is just not at that time and
even now it wasn't that common knowledge
that a lot of kids need vitamin D you
know particularly in the modern worlds
you know there are regularly there are
guidelines that all children need
vitamin D drops you know and he wasn't
getting of buds I've got to say about
four or five weeks before this happened
I was doing some reading I was coming
across this in my own process and I you
know I thought oh my son should be on
vitamin D so what I did is I I found my
wife from work
and I emailed her a protocol I said hey
babe can you just make an appointment
can you see the doctor and just ask cuz
we get told it's drilled into us as
medical doctors in the UK we're not to
make decisions on our own family it's
considered bad practice you consider too
close and so I thought I can't me to do
the right thing
so she printed it off she went to see
her GP and the GP said you know and she
knew he knew that I was a doctor and he
said to my wife you could have just
printed made this up on word that this
is not this is rubbish you don't need to
do anything you know you're doing the
best and so she phoned me and said this
is what's going on at me do a bit more
research and says let me know because I
I wasn't confident enough to make that
call myself right where's now with
hindsight I should have just done it
myself bought the drops over the counter
and
ahem but I didn't what and you know I've
gone through years of trying to figure
out why I didn't do that and you know
having a lot of guilt attached to that
which is a separate issue but I mean
quite an important one because that
guilt see what happens he's in a
hospital he nearly dies
modern medicine saves him but then I
thought I'm reading about vitamin D I
think well this is a critical critical
vitamins for your immune system develop
this is a critical vitamin for his
burnstead abouts he was diagnosed with
rickets as well mmm
right a Victorian illness that he's now
gotten a 21st century and actually it on
a sidenote in the UK rickets is on the
whites which is just incredible Wow not
have thought that I didn't think anybody
got rickets anymore we're going up in
the UK every year I don't know the u.s.
stats but it's going up and and you know
what happened in that moment was that I
thought well maybe this is the reason
he's got eczema
maybe cuz you know cause eczema in some
ways related to your immune system
having an element of dysfunction in it
and instead of just putting creams on to
suppress the symptoms aside well maybe
this is why he's got it so I I felt so
guilty about this that I said why I'm
gonna figure out how to get my son back
to optimal health as if this has never
happened and that was my drive right I
became obsessed I'd be reading I'd be
going on the Internet be reading about
vitamin D and nutrition and as you
stopped reading you start to come across
I Celtic had come across a whole ton of
science that frankly I had never seen
before that I thought why do I not know
about this right that's the shocking
thing why do I not know about this I
learn more I thought right I'm gonna
figure this out I spent a ton of money
of my own money I started going out so
America start coming on conferences on
courses with the goal to get him better
right and I've got to say I'm very very
thankful that my son is thriving he's
eight now he's happy he has no skin
problems he's doing well he's sporty
he's you know I really feel that
everything I've learned has helped me
get him back to full health okay so that
was a it wasn't just the instance of
going to the emergency room and treating
it if this was something that
that required treatment over a prolonged
period of time to get him well but if
it's how you look at it modern medicine
would say well he had a problem he had a
convulsion oK we've identified that and
fixed it you discharged now good to go
okay but we but we're not looking at
what are the implications how long was
he low in that vitamin for how much of
impact has that had on the development
of his immune system right right and
which that kills me Ziva think about
that you know what that might have
potentially done already and what I know
is that if you think about that
threshold concept even if there has been
you know an impact from that which no
doubt that there that has I feel that
I'm helping him optimize everything else
that is possible so you kind of mean
that that is just gonna have less of an
impact but here's the key by the science
I learned from trying to get him better
yes I helped him then as a family we
start applying it in our lives why then
I start applying it with my patients and
I for the first time I meant career I
felt I was excited I thought I'm getting
people better
I'm getting them off their medication
I'm actually understanding what the root
cause of their problem is and how to get
to it and it changed my career and I you
know it's it's you know in some ways
rich if this had never happened to my
son would I be doing what I'm doing yeah
it's that classic thing of you know the
worst thing that happens to you is the
silver lining that that you know creates
something beautiful out of it
I mean silver lining for me it was a
silver lining for him you know I don't
know but I'd be alright
I'm started to do now is I'm I'm really
working hard on myself to let go of that
guilt because actually that guilt
I think it's served its purpose and I
think now that that guilt is hindering
my ability to be as good a good a father
as I could be
yeah you can't keep punishing yourself
and wear the hair shirt yeah
and he doesn't want that either he
doesn't want to start to be guilty you
know and it's
me it was that transformative experience
you know and I kind of jerk are you
suggest about to myself I thought okay
because of that I've learned this I'm
helping my patients now then I get this
BBC one show this primetime show which
goes out to five million people a week
in the UK and then you know 70 countries
around the world where I can showcase
this so to millions of people around the
globe how no matter what your condition
is we can improve it with these
lifestyle recommendations and I thought
you know maybe that's his gift to the
world
maybe he in some ways that's what was
required to give me this drive to do
what I do
yeah that's cool yeah so Wow my head's
gone but no no no it's it's it's it's an
amazing story and I'm sure he's gonna be
fine
hey he is gonna be fine he's he's
incredible in the context of your
practice and all these people that you
treat and see like what is the well two
questions really but the first being
like what is the the number one thing
that people struggle with the most and I
know you don't want to like sort of
parse the differences between these four
pillars because of this you know
delicate interplay between all of them
but you know where where are people
going wrong the most what's the most
chronic persistent condition or
stumbling block that people face in your
experience yeah what is the most well I
think that the most common stumbling
block you're right I mean I I think you
gotta take those four pillars
individually because in different people
it's gonna be a different one but if I
had to really pick one and this is
different from if I did come on the show
five years ago I didn't know you doing
the podcast well if he's a killer worse
yes if I was here five years ago I
would've given you a different answer
back then I would've told you it was
food but now I'd say it's stress mmm you
know I think the majority of people I
see
I just stressed out busy they just got
their brains full of stuff they just
that this there's no quiet there's no
stillness there's no there's no respite
from the noise and I'm finding more and
more I'm going there a lot earlier than
I used to
so I'd say that's probably the big one
for me that's the one that I struggle
with the most
hey me too you know Anna yeah as
somebody who's driven and as an athlete
like I just you know my whole frame of
mind is push push push
I can do more I can make it better and I
just dig myself into a hole which is why
I wake up woke up this morning feeling
so great you know but it's about saying
you can do more yeah and do it all right
but you just gotta you've got to have a
stop point you gotta just you gotta
schedule in these stop points where
because these days it's not matter what
you do your work has never done there is
always something else you can be doing
so I look I'd rather romantically look
back to time 15 20 years ago and I I
imagine that people words and I'm sure
I'm overly you know I'm sure it wasn't
quite like this but I kind of imagined
their you know let's say a working
couple would come back and they might
sort of have dinner with their children
let's say for argument's sake and some
point the children would go off to bed
and then it would be like okay let's
let's chill out together let's maybe put
the television on let's let's watch
something together you know there wasn't
the ability to go right that's done now
I can get on with more work now I can
actually open up my work emails now I
can catch up with what I'm not done yet
now I can get ahead for tomorrow I don't
think for certainly for the largest part
of our revolution we didn't have that
possibility no when you went home you
were home your home work was at work
you're home now
are you chill and he could reach you and
nobody would would unless there was some
crazy emergency yeah exactly so because
we've got the ability to do these things
we always feel we can do more so yeah
that's never gonna go you to-do list is
never gonna be done is it you if you
think you're never gonna take it all off
and you're done now that ain't happening
there's always something else a there's
always an email to get back to there's
always your Facebook to check there's
always a DM
just got an Instagram that you could get
back see you know it's endless now all
that what's up drew you've been attitude
you've got a responsive right well we
all have like twenty inboxes yeah you
know and people can't get you on one to
get you on another one so he's just got
this constant bombardment so I think
that stress peace and a lot of people
don't realize that that is a big risk
factor for disease but that will even
negate you that will even stop you from
losing weight people can't get the heads
around that but so many particularly
I've got to say women okay and that's
because I'm going from my experience I'm
not saying this affects women more than
men what I am saying is in my clinical
experience I've seen a lot of women
suffer hugely with stress and you know a
lot of them are you know witty caring
they don't they don't put themselves
first they put their children first they
put their partner first they put their
parents first they they do everything
for other people they've got no time for
themselves and what happens is because
they're wired the whole time that
cortisol levels which are primary stress
response hormone those levels are high
that persistently raised but if they are
persistently raised it means your body
thinks it's under attack so it holds on
to weight and I've helped women get rid
of menopausal symptoms I've helped them
get rid of their weight problems when
they've jumped from diet to diet for
years and they keep hitting a plateau
and they think what's the right diet you
know this is the wrong diet for me
what's the next book ID my was what's
the perfect diet and I say hey this
ain't a diet tree bottom all of these
pretty good diets your mind never
switches off and just by some simple
stress management techniques the weight
starts coming off or the menopausal
symptoms start getting bad SS stress
impacts everything and you know I see my
price as I saw it when I did doctor in
the house I saw it in people's lives and
you know what I mentioned people sit
back and let's say a couple sitting
watching television in the evening
there's another issue there which is now
let's if we play that a scenario out
let's say the couple do want to watch
something together right actually is
very common now for people to be on
their own devices because we can
personalize everything so I don't need
to watch my wife's watching I can watch
my favorite show she can watch hers so
the whole rod
our own personal experiences on our on
our own yeah
so we're together in the same room but
we're not together together over now
having actually that plays out in other
areas so you know many people come and
see their doctor about you know their
sex life or a lack of intimacy and these
kind of things and the classic cliché
now is as a husband or wife or who
either you know partners - partners are
in bed together right but they're both
on their own devices so that they're
occupying the same physical space yet
actually they're in their own world
their own emails and their own Facebook
messages their own Netflix shows and
that opportunity for intimacy that is
going as well and you know as a dancer
these things come up into my prizes
every day people are complaining about
this and again this technology is so
great on so many levels but if we don't
we don't rein it in it's so facing all
aspects of our life yeah yeah it's crazy
to think that but it's so true
I mean you know sort of what you're
saying on some level is like your device
is making you fat yeah that's the way to
get people to pay attention but that is
the way and then so you could talk about
all the other things but it really is
amazing these crazy times that we're
living in right deal with all this kind
of stuff that even ten years ago was
non-existent yeah I know what we do want
to make clear rich if it people
listening to this and go yeah look get
all that but it's just too hard I'm I
would say look maybe something they've
heard that we've already spoken about or
something they might read about right
just pick something small just pick
something small and start there maybe
it's simply that you'd you want one of
these people who go on your phone and
your bed at nights right what if you
didn't bring into your bedroom or what
if 20 minutes before bedtime
you thought I can I'm just gonna put
this off now okay stop that keep you
know I live in a house and we keep our
phone charges downstairs right and the
rule is but we don't always stick to it
why it's where the rule is is that we
leave our phones downstairs we don't
bring them upstairs into the bedroom
right now I'm a human what we don't
always stick to it are you on call
though at times where you have to have
the phone nearby
no the way I do practice now no I'm not
so I don't need that but look I've
worked with people who do right so I'm
like okay fine on those nights you do it
I get it but what about the other six
nights in the week when you're not right
because we can all make those
justifications that you can make the
justification there I run an online
business I've got to be connected at all
times well you can always make excuses
for whatever it is that you're trying to
wiggle out of yeah one thing is when we
say we're trying to wiggle answer that I
think this is where the empowerment
comes in because at first the first
thing we got to do is people have got a
got a once a change right they might be
listening again yeah you know but I
don't want to do that you know if people
aren't ready for that they may they may
buy my book right and they may read it
and do something for a week but then
they're just gonna put on the Shelf have
it go back to the world habits or more
commonly they'll buy the book and give
it to somebody who they want they want
to help without appreciating the fact
that if that person they're trying to
help doesn't want to change it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter because people
think that they can will people into
that wanting to change mindset and that
is just restr since I go to this world
and since I've suddenly seen the light
yeah you know I'm trying to sing it from
the rooftops so first I've learned that
you know what you cannot make anybody
make these changes you know but say
clean all your family know and I'm sure
you get as I do tons of emails hey you
know something my mom my brother my
husband my wife whatever I mean they
need to understand this how can I make
them understand it you can't you can't
you can't you just gotta I say well you
know and this why 2000 I try and lead by
example you know not because I'm trying
to be an example I just I'm just gonna
concise it's enough work to do it myself
right and this crazy modern world we
live in I'm gonna focus on balance and
bit by bit hopefully people around you
will you know if their interest said you
might just you know spot that a little
bit of interest and I say one place this
has this has played out recently which
is probably not what people will expect
me to say but I you know because I've
got two young children you know
now that they're a school it's always
tricky for me to sort of knowing what I
know I you know I can't control
everything about them anymore
and that's just part of growing up right
but you know often there's a culture at
schools of like sugary junk food all
this kind of stuff which you know witty
or one more I find very frustrating and
an issue when they when my son sada is
school it would stress me out this is
this is crazy what am I gonna do and
then my wife and I decided you know
we're just gonna focus on doing what we
do and at the end of that first year
they went on a school trip and people
could bring their treats and for that
school trip so what we did is that again
we're not trying to make any judgment on
anybody else we're literally always
cautious when we're talking about
children you know I genuinely believe
every parent is trying to do the best
that they can for their child's within
the context of their life and within
their health belief system but we felt
that we want to keep feeding him healthy
nourishing foods you know and we made
these well I say we my wife my wife made
these beautiful fruit kabobs he's I
think that was mangoes or breathe so
these colorful girls and he took them in
and then at their lunch break on their
school trip you know everyone's having
their stuff and he's having his food
come out of which he loves because he
thinks that's a treat you know am i loud
all this super sweet fruit today and it
we went to pick him up and his teacher
said to us so before I was just
incredible you know I think we're gonna
institute this now as a practice for
school trips we're gonna now do these
fruit kabobs for everyone we thought
that was fantastic and I will you learn
a lesson that day I again I thought this
is incredible you know we're not telling
other people what to do I don't feel
it's my place or our place to tell other
people see we just focus on what we do
and that has been observed and other
parents have asked us as well so that's
incredible and now other people are
starting to adopt that with their
children because of what they saw us do
and again it's that same principle that
applies which is you can't make someone
else change you just gotta focus on
doing what you're doing and it is hard
because if you're let's say if you have
had a health revelation by changing your
lifestyle yet your partner is not
you all you want to do is tell them so
now that is you know you do this you do
this but I found it doesn't work no it
doesn't work and it's tough I'm
sympathetic to people that are in that
situation like I was lucky enough to
have you know a wife who was super
supportive I don't know that I would
have made the changes that I would have
been able to make them or make them
stick without that kind of support so
it's very difficult and on the the you
know that the thing about kids I mean
we're very similar with our kids
my wife is an insane cook she makes
amazing food since the food that our
kids prefer but we don't make rules with
them about what they can and can't do
when they leave the house like I'm not
that concerned about whether my daughter
is gonna have a piece of cake at a
birthday party what I am concerned about
is her habits ten years from now and
what her default settings exactly and
that comes through setting the example
and through constant education and using
food the kitchen the farmers market the
grocery store all of that the cooking
teaching them how to make certain things
it's all like a homeschool recipe to
instill you know those those ideals
around food that I think are so
important then it's about serving the
long term yeah and you've got much more
experience than me as a parent you know
so I'm always happy to hear and each
kids different each gets different and
I'm realizing more money to let go and
you know you know at some point they're
gonna push back and experiment and you
know you cannot it's very hard to fight
societal norms but if you don't give
them anything to push back against the
impulse to rebel is is diffused right
you're not saying like oh you know this
is if you're if you're making all these
rules then when they get to a certain
age they're like I'm out of the house I
can break the rule yeah exactly and I'm
you know we become acutely aware of that
recently and really try and modify our
behavior around the kids because off
that and you know I mentioned before
that I I met Michelle Puma there right
even if you've no I don't know her but
he said he said he said you know I think
went out working it down initially to
sort of help do all the research on the
blue zones with them and I was lecturing
with him in Guernsey and Guernsey
looking at guns you'd say could this
qualify potentially as a blues and I
don't know why they've got see with that
but very currently they're they're
people who are organizers arrange for me
and Dan not pins on me and Michelle so
you go and visit some of guernsey
centenarians I remember we went in a
taxi and we went to this chaps house he
102 years old I remember we got out the
taxi and I knocked on the door and he
comes up and he answers the door
which in itself was amazing to me
because as a doctor I do home visits
that's something we still do in the UK
I'll you know someone phones in that
they can't get in we go and obviously
it's a self-selecting population people
are sick and an ill generally frail
that's why they're calling the doctor
but I've never had one of those patients
well very rarely open the door for me
and normally there's a key lock or some
a caravan that's me in this guy rocks up
and he lets me in and we go and we sit
down and there's a cup of tea made for
us and we sit there and we talk that's
where the interesting talk to him about
his life and you know he said until he
was 95 and start seeing dots as he was
great and once he started seeing dogs
his his health went down but he'd
supposed to me I come up the name of
this thing but he said you know one of
his favorite treats
was this Guernsey loaf it's like a
mixture between an English cake and a
French croissant I can't remember the
name affair I was really interested I
thought okay you know cuz I'm trying to
work out what's the secret here you know
and I say you know that's great how
often would you have that would you want
sort of most days or the weekends it's
like oh no does chasity Easter and
Christmas we just have it special times
yeah can't that every day
and I thought that's the key it's not
about and I think this is consistent in
all these blue zones it's not about
deprivation these guys have sweet tweets
they don't have it every day after
school or every mid-morning coffee break
at work right
they haven't now and again it's a
celebration time as a treat and you know
that's why the recommendation I make in
the book is to denormalize sugar why I'm
not saying look we crave sugar if you
were trying to avoid sugar in this
modern food environment I think you're
setting yourself up for failure really
because it's gonna be incredibly
challenging I feel too long so comp
we avoid sugar I think we need to
denormalize sugar you know it just it
can't be that everyday norm it's got to
be the occasional treats mm-hmm that's
the key but I think you have to be
specific about about what you mean by
occasional because I think people have
different definitions of that and I and
I do think and I think you'll agree with
me on this that there's something to be
said for completely cutting something
out like sugar to allow your microbiome
to adjust and your physiology to adjust
and there very well may be some
discomfort because we are addicted to
these kinds of foods and when we remove
them there's a craving that ensues but
if you can if you can kind of wait you
know sort of weather that you can get to
the other side and those cravings
dissipate and your relationship to those
foods that once triggered you and held
so much power over you no longer do Rach
I obviously agree look you know I go
through this process if you want to go
cold turkey on it I've taught people
through how to do that because I'm for
me that's the approach I would take
because you've you you within four or
five days you start to feel you saw to
learn how good you can feel and how
frankly hooked you are on this stuff
right but some people that's too much
for so I was like take them through a
step-by-step process that they can take
if they want to go more gradually but I
agree
often people will say you know I'm
addicted to sugar or yeah but I've got a
sweet tooth you know what we've all got
a sweet tooth we crave sugar but if your
norm is to have sugar in your cereal
even if you're not adding sugar that the
inbuilt sugar in your cereal and your
bread that you have in your sandwich at
lunchtime potentially in some of those
breads and you already made pasta sauce
in the evening right your body gets used
to get your tastebuds adapt to what
you're giving it I remember a few years
ago when I used to drink tea when I
first I'm doing is he had sugar in it
and I remember giving it up the first
few days I couldn't stand the table this
is awful I thought I got used to it
three weeks later I was at work and I
picked up the wrong cup of tea and as
sugar in it I had to spit it out
because
something that I could have drunk three
weeks previously now felt horrendously
sweet to me because our taste buds add
that so yeah I've had the same
experience so I do feel that it's much
better to have a period of let's say two
weeks where you go cold turkey yes you
will may well go through some withdrawal
symptoms okay I don't like it here that
people don't like to hear that but you
know what can will power things through
we can say right you know maybe for four
to six weeks that's harder but we can
willpower for a week or two most people
can my big tip for that and not only for
that my big tip in general for making
lifestyle changes people are serious
about lifestyle change no matter what
that is I would say make your home a
safe zone right if you're trying to
avoid certain foods do not bring them
into the house and the reason is because
in the 21st century in most places now
if you step outside your front door
you'll having to exercise willpower
everywhere you go right you want to fill
up petrol or gas in your car right
you've got a walk pass to all the junk
in there and the petrol station you want
to get a coffee right you know in the UK
it's like this you want to buy coffee
you stand in line right you walk past or
the pan of chocolates or the pastries or
the muffins you may well have mentally
thought right I'm gonna say no you go it
to pay the barista will then say to you
hey sir would you like a Punisher club
with that you know you're constantly
being questioned and pushed so I'm
saying that's gonna be hard no and yeah
ultimately we'll pick willpower is going
to fail you yeah so don't use that your
willpower in the house mmm right I know
you will come back one day tired
stressed-out underslept
right and you will crave something
sweets and this happened to me a few
weeks ago I was you know going around
the country it's talking about the book
talking to people trying to promote
health I was exhausted right sitting
there at home with will you feel like
something's sweet I open the cupboards
it's nothing there's always that's not
sighs I don't feel like all these are
notes of the moment how do you know what
after a little while that craving goes
you're pissed for a minute and yeah
right exactly but that's it but if you
had if I had that that
that bag of potato chips then I would
have smash through it because that's how
I felt and I really feel that it's such
a key point control the environments
that you can control you just you're
setting yourself up for winning I talked
about these these little glutes
exercises I do a lot of my patients that
really help me get rid of 10 year
history of backache I do three to four
minutes of them a day but you know what
I did it I wake up how about at downtime
in the morning I very mindfully and
particularly weigh out my coffee beans
I sort of I weighed all out a little bit
obsessed with it I pour the water in and
then my timer goes on for four minutes
and as the coffee's brewing my step is
there in the kitchen and I do three
minutes of gluten exerciser so it's
inbuilt
into my you know I keep that stepper in
the kitchen right sure my wife's are
huge fan that it lives in the kitchen
but the point is you've got to set these
things up so you can make the lifestyle
change it ain't that hard man honestly
it's not that hard right the the
teachable kind of takeaway is construct
your environment to be conducive to
making the healthy choice and that's you
know what you do in your home is kind of
a microcosm version of what Dan Buettner
talks about in the macrocosm like he
always is saying look you know we can
brow be people into trying to exercise
and eat well but ultimately you're not
going to really solve the problem on
like a Civic level on a social level
until you create infrastructures that
are conducive to that you have bike
paths and you make sure that there are
no you know terrible foods in the
schools like all the stuff so that
everything is sort of out of reach it's
inconvenient to make the unhealthy
choice and everything is set up to be
conducive to driving you towards making
that healthy choice and you can do that
in your home and to the extent that you
can control your environment at work or
at play whatever you know you have the
ability to control that's going to
ultimately pay big dividends long-term
yeah
thus the key right but we look at these
blue zones and I don't feel you know Dan
would clearly know better I spend a lot
of time out there but
I don't feel that these guys are
necessarily trying to be I'm trying to
do anything their environment is just
yeah their environment is just conducive
to them something wrong because they
have to be moving in there
they're just living proximate to their
family members and they're a part of a
faith community like it's all just set
up to promote that without them having
to give it a second thought they don't
need to go to the gym not going to the
gym exactly that just though to get
around to get that food to go and to do
whatever they need to do they need walk
that they're doing this stuff and that's
why I think overall there are two pieces
here one is the education piece right
okay the education piece says you know
books like yours books like mine so many
great books out there to try and help
people understand what they might be
able to do but that's only one part of
the piece right at one part of the
puzzle the other part is the environment
right ultimately that the only time
we're going to get the real public
health gains that are going to transform
your country going to transform my
country when there is infrastructure set
up so that people find it easy to make
those choices
that you know her photo this we see on
my Instagram you know I was in London on
the Underground's and I was in a station
and it was I think two sets of
escalators and then in the middle there
was a set of stairs
nobody on the stairs everyone on the
escalators and can I try and always take
the stairs where I can't take the stairs
yeah and again I'm not again I'm not
trying to sort of sell my - how dare you
you know I really know I get it right I
get it you're so much better yeah I
really don't I share the only DOMA
honestly it's not my it's not my thing
that I die but you see it when people
come offer you know I flew in to LA a
couple of days ago and you get off you
go through customs and everything of
them bears those stairs so that to the
luggage claim hall and there's an
escalator nobody's on the stairs yeah
we've just been sighted did that last
week I know exactly what you're talking
about me sound up but I was the only one
on the stairs yeah we've set up boats
for 12 hours and it's easy because we're
tired from the flight it's easy to son
on the escalator right and I get it and
again I'm not criticizing people for
doing that but this is the point about
the environments even if there was a
sign at LAX right you know
no that's good studies at show in
workplaces if you put a sign on the left
if you put a sign there that's have you
thought about taking the stairs yeah
there's a UK paper I'll send you the
link it's route it's incredible it makes
a difference you just like people
thinking it makes a difference right I
gave as well I gave so my UK publisher
penguin right so a few months ago I gave
them a well-being tour the whole penguin
in London I went to talk to them about
the four pillars basically and they
their offices on the eighth floor of the
building so every time I've gone that I
get escorted up there everyone takes you
to the left and at the end I made them a
challenge I said guys look obviously you
guys personalize this to your own lives
but there's an opportunity here you all
work on the eighth floor you've all been
at this talk it's much easier to make
change in groups and communities
together what if those of you who were
able to you know what if from tomorrow
morning not next week not next January
tomorrow morning you all try to help
each other take the stairs each day you
know how would that be and there was a
you know there was a mixed reaction a
little bit but people I okay you know
that sounds pretty reasonable why I
track this why the next day all of them
took it all in took it okay 100 percent
of people who attended four months later
85 percent of them were taken at four
times a week that's pretty good I would
have thought the attrition would have
been higher really no I would have to
drop off yeah meaning yeah no again I
was surprised but but that goes that
that place that really teaches us how
how much of a role community plays
because if it's the left up to an
individual there hey you go out for
lunch then you have to come back and you
sell half a staple if what if your
colleague says yeah I know but why don't
we just take the stairs why when you do
it in a group together you start to make
those changes and I've got emails from
so many people when penguin saying hey I
didn't realize the impact I had I've I
feel better about myself I'm more
productive in the afternoon my
relationship with my wife is better
since I started doing that I'm sleeping
better and I'm not kidding you this is
not me exaggerating how powerful these
changes are
so these little changes bit by bit these
small changes become our new habits
these new habits become our health you
got to start somewhere and now it
doesn't matter yeah babe these guys
won't changing their diets right
all these guys did right let's take the
stairs together four times a week it's
eight blocks of stairs Yeah right people
that email is saying all these kind of
great benefits and what that does that
then makes them feel better then they
want to make a diet change
well then they think you know I wonder
what else I could do maybe this fifteen
minutes and meantime isn't all weird
maybe I can actually do this and and
that's why I'm passionate saying one on
one with someone I will try and find a
spot that I can really connect with them
where I think okay you know and find
something that they can agree with
either agree sit with me that the
difficult I had with writing a book is I
really believe in a personalized
approach so I thought how the hell do I
write a book for the general population
that personalizes it and the way I've
tried to do is by give people options
give people so many options
real life options right not that I
fabricate it but that I have seen over
nearly 20 years that patients have
reported back telling me this works in
my life right not what the research
paper says yeah that's all in that right
people want to read the research I can
give them that but what I think I'm most
proud of is that this book is making
people want to make lifestyle change
because they think yeah I can do that
Wow I relate to that person he's just
told me about well I'm gonna start there
and it's been out for a few months in
the UK and it's just it's it's really
transforming the way people are thinking
about health you know the four pillar
frameworks but it's almost I want quite
goes what I was saying it's in common
parlance yeah but a lot of people are
talking about it a lot of doctors a lot
of health care providers a lot of
nutrition professionals are raising the
concepts in their little 10 minute
consultation and then giving them the
book at a psychiatrist contact me last
week a psychiatrist saying hey doctor
can you talk to you publish as I've
actually bought 30 copies of your book
and I've given them to 30 and my
patients but so anyway we can get a
discounted rate right because this is
not just about type 2 diabetes and
obesity this
is about mental health problems it's
about gut symptoms this is about
migraines insomnia depression you know
it's about all these things these are
the chronic diseases this is what I'm
seeing day in day out as a doctor and
this is what I'm seeing that frankly a
one pill solution
it ain't working for the book these
people working and I'm sorry said go on
I've just I know this works I've seen
this work and I just want people to give
it a shot give it a chance the beauty of
it is the accessibility and and and and
the fact that the ask is so digestible
it's like what is the what is the one
thing that you can change what's the
tweak that doesn't take up any time and
doesn't cost any money that can ignite
you and get you engaged in your life in
a different way
and allowing that person to explore that
take ownership of it and go on their
journey yeah so the call they're really
the call to action and we're going to
land this plane the call to action to
everybody listening is you know what
does that change for you what is that
what is that one small thing that you
can agree to that can begin to catalyze
that shift yeah absolutely
it really is about that one thing that's
the star and you know I mean I don't
never age what would be the one thing be
for you haha I think for me I mean
there's a whole there's a litany of
areas where I could use some improvement
but I think you know I have challenges
around eating food late at night that I
know of it negatively impacts my sleep I
have issues about turning the devices
off you know within a given timeframe
before going to bed those are two big
ones and I have a tendency to push
myself too hard in in work and in play
that leaves me depleted and so I don't
carve out I get uncomfortable when it
comes time to carving out like
relaxation and reflection time yeah and
I'm not dissimilar to that if I'm honest
I mean I've
recently particularly since I've looked
at all the circadian rhythm research
from from captain excuse me from
California on you know not easing too
late at night which is just incredible
I've really tried to limit that but I
struggle its call that time for myself I
will sometimes you know particularly
when traveling and your time zones are
all off your honor stuff you start
looking at devices oh but I wonder I
mean I know you were interviewing me but
I'm just I thought it's like this whole
what I do at a consultation is I say
what ok these are things you're
struggling with
perhaps I can also commit to something
at the same time as it may be from the
next seven days we can sort of make a
commitment to each other that we're
gonna try and do this one thing and I
have done that with patients before so
yeah what are we gonna commit to here
what about devices before bed and we are
how are you feel about that I can do
that what sure I can what's achievable
achievable um ninety minutes before bed
you think ninety minutes I think I could
do that yeah
yeah so it's what I call a no tech 9c I
do it we're gonna do it okay I will also
commit is it doable for you it is I
think so you know it's I went through a
really good patch a couple of months ago
I was doing it all the time and I fallen
into a few bad habits but this is
renewed me this is being like okay I've
made a commitment to rich that I'm gonna
do I think I can do it as well alright
we'll check in with each other yeah and
anyone who's listening and wants to let
us know if they can do it as well they
should let us know right right yeah for
sure like bullet yeah why don't we make
it a hash tag or something yeah hashtag
no tec-9 say no tech 90 alright that is
there you go no technology let us know
when you hear this not in the 90 minutes
of read do it the next morning
right cool final question and then I'll
let you go and I ask this of all doctors
that come on the show if you woke up in
a parallel universe and you would become
an American citizen been appointed to
become Surgeon General what what changes
do you put in place you know what I
should have prepared about to like your
podcast so besides that I have just no
say I mean on account of whether its
regulatory or legislative like what kind
of system
changes would you like to see in health
or the practice of medicine I would say
that culturally I feel like legislative
changes that precise health so I would
like it to be almost in legislation that
schools and hospitals don't sell junk
food right those stock junk food let's
start there even yeah will be
transformative and another I guess
systemic change would be to really push
companies and this culture particular I
think you have it in American more than
any other country this you know this
work hard constantly be on call always
be available on your phone always be
available we need to take a leaf out of
like a German company I think box if I
can do this recently where their
employees and physically cannot access
their emails in the evenings weekends
and on a holiday time they're just locks
out right and again it may not be what's
fun I think it is but one of the German
companies and it's very common in Europe
now for this to be implements it I think
that would be a huge thing for America
if that corporate culture will change
where we accept hey you're going home
now I do not expect you're my boss does
not expect me to answer an email till
8:30 tomorrow morning when I back at my
desk I think even that's because I think
many people have got the expectation
they don't want to lose their job like I
only said we're pie to my boss even
those small things will have a huge
impact yeah beautiful man thank you so
much rage the pleasures been mine and
just such incredible honor for me to be
here I you know 5,000 miles away I'm
going up and down the country on the
train to London I'm often listening to
your podcast I'm often learning a lot
from what you you've gleaned from your
guess is what I thank you for the
opportunity to come and there and talk
to myself thank you awesome thank you I
appreciate that that's very cool to hear
excited for you excited for the new book
the book is in the UK it's the four
pillar plan you'd see it here on video
and in the u.s. they have changed the
title it is how to make disease
disappear why do they change the diet
Americanized there's gonna be more
totally different cover the whole thing
contents the same yeah the context same
so depending upon where you live those
are the titles pick it up wherever you
buy find books and come back and talk to
me sometime I'd let say cool time if you
want to connect with dr. Chatterjee
what's the best place to do that we say
Facebook or Instagram it's at dr.
Chatterjee it's probably best place to
get hold of me and we can have a
conversation on there or possibly my
podcast feel better live more podcast
people can listen to that as well and
yeah me at that on iTunes and all usual
places yeah cool are you doing any
public speaking events that are open to
the general public some people yeah like
no well by the time this goes up is
there like a schedule on your website or
anything like that yeah we're putting on
the websites on dr. Chatterjee calm it's
also on my Facebook page facebook.com
forward slash dr. Chatterjee there's an
Events section there where all my all my
events are there so yeah I love speaking
to the public so if you if you want to
come along please state awesome and
final thing are you gonna take us all
out with a little guitar we didn't even
talk about the fact that you're a
touring rock star you like tickety took
like a sabbatical from your medical
practice tour with your band I did yeah
yes what's the name of your band here
Isis well I did under my own name the
solo EP it was something wrong again it
was when i reck'n dey's one had long
hair you know it did my deed you have
long hair I did yeah I feel pressure
than I want to play do you want to I'm
in it's up to you well I'm here in
single feels right I'm here in the in
the hills in California and
yeah let's this this will be a cover
with you good
[Music]
feel free to sing why matter hey you
don't want that
wanted ever traveled is another salad
with it on my minds for the one want me
to don't wanna Stoney wants a she's a
friend of mine take it easy take it easy
[Music]
don't let the sound of your wheels try
too crazy
you still can don't even try to
understand the second place to find your
step and take what Matt is standing on a
corner Winslow Arizona such a fine sight
to see
it's a girl my lord and a flatbed for
some damn I ever look at me again
take it easy
told that the sound if your wheels drive
you crazy enough you still can don't
even try the understand just find a
place to make your stand and take it
[Music]
but a jet like in the voice
I don't play that a few years right now
and that was great little Eagles for
California I'm saying this way that's
what I felt like awesome man thank you
and so nice time buddy all right peace
Lance
[Music]
you